walk him to this video playing Zeke
Motta from Turkey Turkish flag at least
okay he's playing soft perks perks
defense reversed and this is has been a
favorite setup of mine against this for
a while okay he's some transposing to
the to the ratty with c4 okay
yeah what I'm trying to do is as best as
possible block the queenside b5 our
place see five if he takes I'm taking
with the e night and then night a six
and I to be for the Sun set up
trying to block it on the queenside and
then initiate play in the center pin
with f5 and you for possibly okay sorry
should I play don't know Bishop f8
covering or no I may be the smaller be
six would be helpful yeah this is this
you can do but it also gives up some
important squares here or be sure 195
actually yeah let's go here yeah 11 one
problem with this is the night is nicely
placed here but there's f5 coming it's
not a stable position here
yeah it's probably trying to make a
sacrifice out of it I wonder yeah it
should I go back five really then there
are other possibilities i mean this is
this is a good move for example trying
to exchange the light squared Bishop I'm
not quite sure what his next moves on
he's got it does not have such a
clear-cut plan available what I definite
are and no no he's allowing me to
exchange let's do that I actually can't
can go here Knight c3 it's quite quite
annoying
are those pieces are not well placed
okay is giving up the exchange yeah if I
play Knight c3 is probably just going to
take it Kevin and this one yeah or queen
d 5 for 25 this is better okay this I
didn't even consider which is a mistake
of course not considering it I mean hmm
now the national ad for now this was
better
ok Knight b6 I'm taking this this night
ok let's let's let's prepare that it's
it's just strategically right and his
pieces are basically dead here b3 and
the kinda stuff Knight b6 I can go
Queenie six ok
yeah now i'm even threatening good to
dig with the check take it on auto III
III is not not an unattractive but okay
I think getting the e-file open is
probably more important and now here I
am Bishop to e3 this means you cannot
miss the night on c4 take and rookie to
whom
I'm not sure I an end game is enough
here I can get a 5 may be inside or no i
don't i don't know if i should be
content with that now and I'd rather
play on with the Queen's on the bottom
that's Queen d5 checkya we are still and
96 move maybe I should have exchanged
stuff okay but it's so it's not much
more than a check young king edge yet
check and g4 hangs so
check yeah night f7 Kingi seven is not
not so terrible
and I still should have gone for the end
game would have been much easier really
time warning
yeah I take the endgame out just before
it's going to to make me or anything not
sure what is I need to exchange anyway
night see one maybe not see one
I want what's going on in check check
one hundred percent sure how to win it
check check check check now with the
check out didn't didn't really need to
do that white foreheads on time yeah it
was a very nice position but I probably
spoiled it somewhere and I could have
could have one much quicker i believe
down here here maybe you fall directly
but okay Jan I'm an exchange up already
it's not like I'm playing with only
museum it felt like I was giving him a
bit more than then what's necessary
caramel ikkaku Poisson minus free all
the time check probably am also still
still okay check here maybe there were
better moves but I think I always kept
them kept advantage alright thanks for
watching